all right
[Applause]
[Music]
tell those people to watch out watch
their legs watch their legs
stop
[Music]
cool
yeah
one two three what's the location yeah
[Music]
get a chance
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
how you doing sir
[Applause]
foreign
thank you
don't you drive
huh
hey man hey why it's sinking
any idea why
[Applause]
check it out back it up
not neutral in neutral
all right come on you're not gonna be
able to do that bro come on you ready
one two three
all right
yeah okay all right
go to the front of the boat
you're good
oh there he is down there yeah been
waving his arms
on the other on the other side yep
why don't you get out we'll pull it up
yeah she's already going down again
grab onto him put it around your body
yeah put the Rope around the body
all right guys
she's not going to be able to hold on to
her guys hold on baby all right here
okay is there a way that we could make
so we can like grab this one she's fine
right here wrap it around your body we
give her more rope hold on just hold on
three
hold on don't try to pull yourself up
grab that one too
wrap it around your body
on your shoulder Shield
away
if you can all right
yeah
we're gonna get out of your way
people
we got an ambulance right here
hey we'll put her in ambulance one
because they're right there
we go all right we got it all right you
guys got the ladder okay
right
come come over and talk to me I want to
hear what you have to say man I'm gonna
try
I try so hard nobody would help me let
me die but you've never talked to me
right let me let me try to help you okay
what's your name dear nobody would help
me everybody
what's your name dear
let me try to help you okay I don't
think I've ever met you before
I try so hard can you come back over on
this side of the fence for me so we can
talk this out
no no no
163 he did something or whatever we need
a rescue rope just south abroad on the
east side
she's still swimming
hold on to that
I try
this can stop all right grab onto the
Rope hold on to the Rope dear
God
you're all right dear
you're fine
please please
let me go please please
[Music]
I don't know
What's It Gonna
straight down
Eric get over here Betos
what happened we're coming
Eric get down here and re-entry and flip
it in
ah let's go guys
I'm not seeing any movements
[Applause]
before uh
do you want more help with traffic
control
all right
we don't need any help for traffic
control cars in the river
God
outside
[Applause]
let's go
you sure you got what are you doing
where's the winch at
least he starts balling them up there
on this side though
all right
where you want me
anybody hear us
hello
there's a bear Brian get up here
though get up here
please what do you need me Paul
yeah
you need to go to the shore I got this
door
hand him out hang on hang on hang on
don't move it what's your life
hang on we got guys in got one in the
car
anybody got scissors cut the belt yeah
yeah
she's definitely hypothermic she's crazy
let's go come on
corner
straight in good baby
we've been doing CPR on her she's been
throwing up a little bit
into the river
yeah we got him
come over here
I don't have a rope
a rope
[Music]
yep
I can't man please
[Applause]
do you have a rope
come on little brother
you're fine
[Music]
[Applause]
where are they at
least
okay
yeah just watch it for us okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
side right now we're going to try to
give her the throw rope
you got it
hold on
yeah of course
we got one out of the vehicle we're
getting two others now
incredible
over there
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
baby
she can open it up there
[Applause]
come on it's okay
you save me
all right there's more things to worry
about all right
here just get back here
yeah I'm done
he's gone yeah he's far
I'm just now reaching them um we're a
Vista just to the West in the wash
all right I know wait a minute
no no I'm just holding on to you
from the south side you're not gonna be
able to get to it stand up
[Applause]
all right can you do me a favor
wrap your wrap your other arm around my
left shoulder
good
[Applause]
all right
are you able to jump up on my back
should try
it wrap all the way around I got you as
long as you can hold yourself up
good okay
yep I'm good
you're good
we're just gonna get to the front of
this house
you're good
they're good
yep
what's this address
before I have uh the mail right now in
the side of the house I don't know the
other side I'll try and get it something
oh
Jake I'm trying to walk he's elderly and
he can only take a few steps at a time
get my snack
s
I don't know if I want you sitting on
this stuff because if this goes you go
I'm trying to work my way over here
let's let's try and get a little more
strength and once we get over we're good
you want I'll carry most of the weight
can you see if we can
hold on I want to get him off this
before he mess with the locks because I
don't want
them don't move those locks yeah
I wish they would just open this garage
it's already got water in there
for sure did that guy
is the owner of the house but back here
behind you guys yeah I didn't was that
the one that was was that the one that
was on the other side
I gotcha
you can lean on me too
[Applause]
good
take it one step at a time there's a lot
a lot of debris in here okay
okay if if we can step to the left a
little bit I can get his right arm you
can get his left arm yeah
[Applause]
go ahead and put your put your arm
around me
all right
when you relax on your on your shoulder
that way we can just kind of pick you up
you want to just grab it
got caught on the fence no you did good
twisted
I was thirsty but not anymore
I drank a bunch of that filthy nasty
water
[Laughter]
probably yeah
so
you ready oh hang on I got a tractor in
last week
start going again
we're good
he already had his cement truck out here
what happened to it
[Applause]
let's get him
put me on that ground though you want
the bucket yeah
or do you want to sit up on the bed
you pull that tailgate down I'll sit on
that
that's fine
the truck's not as cool when you got to
lift someone up on it
a little bit yeah
yeah you want some water or anything no
I mean yeah
I know but you're sure